this lecture is play like a pro and
today I'm not going to necessarily show
games of pro players but I'm going to
show opening z' and why they're not
common at the professional level and
also show like a lot of amateur openings
which are either refuted or close to
refuted a lot of gambits that you guys
might enjoy playing and so basically
what a professional would do against
them okay so hopefully that sounds fun
if you guys have like any openings you
want to focus on any like really
annoying gamuts that you face I know you
mentioned Kings gambit which maybe at
some point I can give recommendation for
a black anything else come to mind
elephant gambit let me ask you guys so
what do you guys play against me for
it's just French right French French d5
okay that's actually good because I have
a few different French lines and I have
a few different 45 lines know what the
max thing okay fair enough
let's I'm gonna go in order here and for
this lecture like the openings I go over
their openings that you could
potentially play if you know your
opponent plays a specific opening if you
know your opponent plays like the Danish
gamut or The Goring gamut then listen
closely because that's what I'm gonna
cover it first
now the Danish gambit it's very popular
opening among lower level players it's
maybe even like the first opening that
many players learn where it's
essentially the idea is to give away not
just one pawn but two pawns together
position like this with very much
accelerated development and two bishops
open position and this this can be
something that black will struggle
against it like the lower levels so I
would like to show my recommendation
like if I were to play a tournament
tomorrow and I play e4 e5 is black I'll
show what I would do again
going back here to to the position after
c3 I do not accept the gambit I play a
line which prioritizes development and
peace activity and I can highly
recommend playing this move on d5
what this does is it pretty much forces
like to take and then we take with Queen
even though the Queen's coming out early
white doesn't have Knight c3 immediately
and there's many ways for black to
maintain the Queen in the center while
bringing in other pieces with initiative
so usually usually white will take on d4
and we can play knight c6 attacking the
pawn white will usually defend with
Knight f3 and we can continue developing
with attack Bishop g4 now already this
looks nice for black now I will say a
lot of players who play like the Danish
gambit will be happy going into this
line because there's a pretty famous
trap from this position where White has
a very sneaky move Bishop e2 and the
point of this move is that it looks like
black can win a pawn but if black tries
to win the pawn will be severely
punished so let's imagine Bishop take f3
Bishop take F to be Queen take T for why
is this terrible for black yeah yes yeah
this should take c6 removal of the
garden this comes with check and black
is is losing the Queen next move so if
you go into this line as black don't
take on f3 and then take on d4 that's
that's one way to lose really quickly so
instead black can just continue
developing and play this move Bishop b4
nice move
forcing white to block White will
usually play Knight c3 now black still
has to be accurate here cuz white does
inherently have more space with the D
pawn and White's ready to castle and
then after castling the pin will be no
longer existing and then the Queen will
be attacked so there's a very specific
way that if you play this line you
should know up and up until this point
and also know
a few moves further down the line best
move for black in this position may look
counterintuitive especially with what we
just saw
but that's move is a bishop take out
three and after a bishop take f3 again
we can't take on d4 because if bishop
takes you six but we have a very
powerful square for the Queen
so black to move here where should the
Queen go yes Queen c4
this is very nice opening preparation
and after Queen c4 we're not winning the
pawn but we're applying a lot of
pressure
we're also preventing light from
castling so this King is stuck in the
center we have threats of both Bishop
takes c3 and also Knight take d4 and if
white doesn't play precisely here then
white can get at worst position very
easily now the most precise way for a
white to play is to first capture on c6
remove the night let me ask you guys
would you take with the pawn or with the
Queen
take with pawn what do you guys think
Chris first impression queen so two
votes for applauding one vote for Queen
the best move is actually to take with a
pawn even though this is allowing double
pawns we want the Queen to be on c4 to
prevent white from casting and we'll see
you later on in the game the these
double pawns aren't that weak because
White's won't have too many ways to
attack them and they're very easily
defended and White's still under
pressure here because Queen on c4 is
very annoying the threat is still Pitts
Bishop take d3 or Bishop takes c3 and if
I move like Bishop d2 is played that
would lose d4 so White's best option
usually is to play Queen e2 so just an
issue at the Queen trade and then blacks
should be happy taking on you too and
then queenside castling now this might
not seem like the most exciting line
because a lot of pieces got traded very
early on and it just seems kind of like
a balanced position but this is actually
a very nice position for black and
there's a lot of potential to outplay
whites in this sort of queenless middle
game where essentially black has a very
clear target that isolated pawn in d4
and black has a way to attack the pawn
with all the the different pieces and
just to illustrate this out up here that
black would like to go for usually the
knight should go to f5 ve7 the bishop
can drop back to b6 and the rooks can
quite often double up on the D file and
then there would be what there would be
already four attackers if black achieves
that Sun up and also if there's any
potential pin along the D file which
could happen quite often then c5 could
be a resource as well
additionally these pawns on and actually
all of the Queen side pawns are very
easily defended not only with this rook
d6 move but also with King b7 so if you
get to this position and just remember
where your pieces should go I think
Black has very good chance in style play
White's
I played this line once before in a
tournament game many years ago was back
in high school and I played it against a
player who had like a very aggressive
style like he likes to to have attacking
positions with Queens on the board and
this is usually the style of most Danish
gambit players where they they want to
be attacking early on so if you can find
some opening preparation like this which
neutralizes the position and kind of
goes against their style and can be very
powerful so hopefully that makes sense
to everyone
if anyone wants to look into this
further you can find games in chess base
we just click search here in the
database there's been over 200 games
played from this position and and black
has a pretty good score what's that
also Lee chest yeah yes I'm using chest
base for this lecture if we were on me
chest we could just go into the Masters
database or they'll be chess database
but one thing that actually like kind of
sticks out in this position and maybe
you can see the rating differential like
black and I've sorted by black rating
but we can see like the black the top
black players are usually playing much
lower in and white players so yeah I
wanted to to make one more point here
that if we go back to the starts we saw
the Danish gambit with d4 immediately
The Goring gambit is when white plays
Knight f3 first and then plays d4 and
then after you take T for white can play
c3 and this is the start of the Goren
gambit and again I mean you could accept
the gambit but I would recommend playing
d5 here and this should lead to just a
direct transposition if if white takes
we take pawn takes Bishop g4 it's the
same position we had before so it makes
sense
do you find this useful of being only e5
player here so you could run into this
okay yeah if you always take then this
is uh this is a nice way to mix things
up so let's move on I'll try and get
some variety given that I have a few
more e4 e5 lines but will will try and
be fair and balanced and we'll we'll
take a look at a French gambit yeah if
you're a French player you should at
least know what the Miller berry is and
you should know some extent to how of
how to to deal with it it can be a very
very dangerous opening if you're not
prepared yeah it's a type of opening
like if you're not prepared you can run
into trouble like very early but if
you're well prepared you should get a
better position from the opening so
French defense will see one of the most
common variations at least to start with
advance variation pawn e5 and of course
idea of the French is to try and break
down White's White's pawn Center well I
played c3 Knight c6 this is all very
standard white will usually play Knight
f3 one quick test for you guys Bishop e5
is a move that will be played by a lot
of amateurs because it looks like a pin
and I guess sometimes people like pins
in this case it's not such a great move
because black has a simple response
Bishop d7 and then after Knight f3 black
is actually winning a pawn it was very
well-known tactic here yeah both of you
what is it yeah Knight taking five just
a classic French tactic given that this
bishops undefended if white takes back
on e5 we take on b5 and if Bishop takes
you seven we take back with the Knights
it's free play
so that's useful to know light will
usually find out of three Queen b6 main
line and now the start of the Milner
berry of the start of the Milner berry
is when white plays Bishop to d3 and
this is this is a sneaky move because it
looks like whites leaving the plum
defendant undefended right away on d4 of
course black can't take this pawn even
though there's what three attackers and
there's two defenders if black takes
takes takes take sticks if you say takes
takes take sticks too many times in a
row it sounds like steak steak steak and
then I got hungry but anyway um after
Queen take tea for white to move yeah
there should be five simple tactics so
the pawn is defended by tactics
essentially however when white plays
Bishop d3 usually the intention will be
to sacrifice a pawn and the best move
for a black here is to take first and
then play Bishop d7 and now what we're
doing we're blocking the the future
Bishop b5 check and now we are
threatening to take the pawn on d4 so
the the Milner berry is when white
castles I will say that a lot of players
will kind of walk into this position
unknowingly as whites and just like so
far whites just played natural moves and
then they'll realize here that their
pawn is in danger and then they'll start
trying to defend the pawn but it turns
out white has no great way to hold on to
the pawn I get Bishop e3 then b2 hangs
right and if if Bishop c2 there is uh
there's a nice move for black in this
position anyone yeah night before very
strong essentially not really focusing
on the pot any more but focusing on this
Bishop and if black can take the bishop
and get rook c8 there's some nice
initiative also combine that with Bishop
e5 and this LightSquared Bishop for
black and very quickly come to life
so castling is the best attempt for
white to to get compensation for the pun
and you're a French player and you take
my pond yeah okay so taking the pond is
the best approach but you have to know
what to do after white takes back and
then light will play Knight to c3 this
is a very key moment because whites
actually giving you another pawn to
capture on e5 question is do you capture
it or do you do something else
so you know you know this do you know
this oh so your younger brother knows it
and you don't well okay so I want to
hear from you first you take the pawn
what do you do what do you do you don't
play the French what would you do would
you take the pawn or do something else
uh-huh yeah so taking the pawn I mean it
looks great I mean you've just won both
of white Center pawns and you're keeping
your own Center Khan's but you're
severely behind in development and the
problem is its line as white gets very
quick initiative Ricci one let's say
let's say your queen goes back you say
you blunder with Queen Oh Queen c7 yeah
there's a knight 85 right and that would
be tragic it's probably going to be
tragic anywhere your Queen moves because
if Queen d6 a very strong move for a
White Knight d5 and you're just getting
hit from multiple directions if you play
Queen c6 here just trying to save
yourself then there's Bishop at four and
like White has brought in like the rest
of his pieces while making threats and
your whole King sides undeveloped and
now there's threats of Knight c7 there's
also ideas of rook c1 I don't think
black is going to be surviving for too
long
so I guess the lesson here is you want
to be greedy but not too greedy like you
take the first fun
don't take the second pun and you're
exactly right if you've seen this before
then this is very important to remember
a six is a very strong move for black it
looks like a waste of time I mean it
seems like blacks should focus on
kingside development but this is a very
strong prophylactic move in these
situations if you can just slow down or
in this case prevent White's source of
counterplay then white will actually be
the one struggling to find compensation
for the pun and because now there's no
no more ideas of 95 it's actually hard
for a white to find a great way to to
proceed in the position I'll show you
some some preparation here and I think
well they'll end up doing with this
lecture I'll I'll put everything on
leech s so if you want to access all of
the files and analysis all include
everything you know a public study that
you guys can can access and we'll leave
a link in the video description Bishop
one Bishop III so yeah Bishop III the
the big difference here is after black
takes e5 white just doesn't have much
counter play yeah like I mean you would
like to target the queen but black is
going to develop in just a couple more
moves and black will actually be the one
developing with tempo right so the best
approach for white is to hold on to the
pawn play and move like Queen e2 and if
you're if you're a very serious French
player I recommend learning the
disposition deeper and kind of knowing
the the subtle you know this so what you
play here 97 very good this is the best
way to develop
ah okay you might even know more than me
here
King each one is a main line that I have
and this is a main idea for a white is
to play f4 now I don't know I have a
different idea now you suggest in knight
c6 this is interesting
I'll include this as a variation because
you it's very possible you you're better
prepared than me because I'm not a
French player
you said f4 and Knight d4 I'll have to
look into that that looks nice and
aggressive especially if you can get rid
of the bishop or if the bishop moves
back to be one
oh so you know this even deeper queen C
for her maybe you should be teaching the
classic toughness do you know a deeper
from here Queen C for it's probably the
last move of your ear crap
and then he was just rolling all over
the bishops e6 coming interesting I will
see anything immediately wrong with this
if I were to like prepare this seriously
I would check it with an engine just to
make sure it sounds but I like that idea
maybe I should play ah but a three runs
into Queen Tiki five nice initiative I
was going to show my line looks
completely inferior to that I was going
to show Queen b6 it looks slow but the
idea is to play d4 and Bishop c6
activate the bishop and the line I had
prepared was d4 and then Knight f5 and
then it's a nice kind of positional
setup for for black holding on to the d4
pawn very clear squares for both the
bishops I guess there's one thing to
realize here that if white ever goes for
g4 Black's happy to play 93 and then the
bishop coming to c6 will be very
powerful
even if black wins right even if black
loses a this pawn on e3 black having two
bishops is a very nice edge to have in
this position
so I guess there's more room for
analysis but to dig deeper after after
this but hopefully for okay for you and
any of the the French players watching
if you haven't seen this h6 move before
it's um it's kind of a do-or-die moment
like if we if we just look up the stats
here in the database
Asics most popular move scores very well
for black like white scores forty
percent out of over seventeen hundred
games Queen techie five has been played
but white scores better here I mean it's
still a fight and like the line I showed
before is probably inaccurate for blacks
somehow and there's probably ways for
black to survive but it's not a risk
that you would want to take
so I think well we'll move on and
continue looking at some some different
openings okay I want to show an opening
for the white side how many of you play
e4 beautiful okay all you four players
let's flip the board I want to show a
lion that if you're an e4 player you've
probably encountered at some point so
let's ask a follow-up question how many
of you have encountered Scandinavian
where you take the pawn and they play
Knight f6 all of you had this position
before you haven't had this before this
is um okay this is slightly less common
than Queen take d5 which is probably
most common thanks to John Bartholomew
but 90 f6 is also quite playable
I think Magnus Carlsen played this in
the protesting had like a beautiful
woman's black but it's it's a risky lion
to play as black if white is well
prepared so let me ask you another
question how many of you have played
against us have actually studied this
line you studied this what do you play
against it oh you play d4 and you you
would probably transpose into some more
main line
oh the wing gab or the this before move
but you can only play that against Queen
Queen and take D 5 and then Queen a5 so
that this is a bit different if you play
T 4 here this is probably the most
common move as far as I understand black
is is getting a fine position after
Bishop g4 I would recommend a more
challenging variation to tonight at 6
and I'll admit that I I don't have like
every line prepared but I have kind of a
good start of what the recommendation
should be for whites I'll actually keep
this on training mode for now but the
move I recommend here is Bishop b5 I
think this is a the best move to fight
for an advantage what we're actually
trying to do is is holding on to the the
d5 pawn we're forcing black to block and
d7 let's say Bishop d7 and then we play
Bishop c4 so we obstruct the Queen from
attacking the pawn and we're trying to
hold on so pot now there's a few
different lines for black here I think
the two main moves are either Bishop to
g4 or b5 I want to start with b5 because
this is uh this is an exciting variation
to show and what I'm gonna show you is
somewhat of a secret novelty like I I
don't think I've shared this with too
many other players I may have played a
game on stream in this line like once
but I've never had this in like a
tournament game so this is slightly
secret preparation okay Bishop b3
logical move let's say black plays a
fine white can play a 4 here
preventing black from playing a form and
we're approaching the the key moment
have you seen this before or no okay so
this is a key moment where the next move
that light plays is actually the least
common move according to the that
database it's not quite a novelty but
it's incredibly strong move and it's a
move that the that the computer
recommends and the Commuter actually
loves this move it was very surprising
those yes bishop a to know
bishop take a fork bishop a to am bishop
take a four I think have been played
more times than than the best move in
this position
you said Bishop c4 know what else can
like consider a part for moving the
bishop
you said Queenie - you said rook take a
four yeah rook take a four is a move
just to show the database like the stats
are interesting here because White has
played
yeah White has played all the bishop
moves more times and rook take a four
rook take a four has only been played
three times but it's a top computer move
in that there's some very like deep
preparation resulting from this exchange
sacrifice and this is something like if
you know this line you could very easily
get against like a strong player like a
strong master could stumble into this
and if you're prepared further you could
get a very nice advantage from early on
so usually black will be inclined to
take and trying weather in the storm you
take back and let's say Knight be d7 and
you have to be accurate here with with
how you kind of maximize your your
temporary advantage because you're more
developed or your I should say your your
quicker to Castle than black and you
have to play accurately to prevent black
from castling so the move to start with
here is to play Knight map 3 what we
want to do is play 95 and start
targeting this 997 which is pinned if
black tries to take on d5 I doubt this
is at all good I mean for starters
there's Bishop c6 like could even also
consider Knight e5 and white should be
happy to go into this usually black will
play g6
actually I shouldn't say usually black
will play because there's been so few
games in this but I think the most human
move is to play g6 going for a Bishop g7
and castling and this is where White has
a nice continuation to just not allow
back to to complete complete castling
starting with 95 Bishop g7 and now
knight c6 very nice outpost and then
after Queen to c8 c4 and black is just
stuck here like black can't Castle now
Queen C it was only moved for black and
now if black castles there's this fork
97 I mean while this this structure for
white is just so difficult for black to
deal with you play a six
yeahi six I mean it's an attempt to try
and get rid of the d5 fun in there's
Queen e2 and now the pawns pinned and
attacked twice and like the knight can't
really move away because the bishop is
always eyeing via x-ray vision if the
knight moves away they're benign a7 so
it feels like looks long yeah and the
computer will give like plus 1/2 plus
1.5 around this position which is a huge
advantage given that white is is down
the exchange for a pawn the black is
just stuck I think the top move is
something like King f8 and then I can
just castle and black is still stuck
like this rook can't really enter the
game on h8 or eight for that matter an
e7 is a constant problem for black like
white is ready to play moves like rook
e1 and Queenie to also complete
development like why it has so many
natural ways to improve and black will
just be stuck so
I first saw this several years ago my
friend actually shared it with me and it
was a friend's secret but now the secret
is being revealed
so I've realized sometimes it's more fun
to share opening preparation because if
I can't get it myself in a game at least
maybe I can show it to other people who
will get it in the game what about John
Baum well John yeah John usually takes
on d5 and then goes back to d8 so
sometimes yeah maybe maybe I'll trick
him like once I actually trapped John on
one of his streams with it with this
different trap I can show that real
quick it wasn't okay it wasn't gonna be
part of this lecture but I'll just show
how I I trapped him in the scandi cuz he
usually takes with Queen and then plays
Queen a5 and this is where I play a
somewhat dubious gambit
I play d4 which is actually a very
effective let's opening because black is
under immediate pressure and after Queen
take d4 Knight d5 hitting the c7 pawn
I've trapped a good handful of players
over the years now after Bishop c4 this
is where black has to be very very
careful and realized White's threat the
first question is what is White's threat
and most often black will miss the
threat and play and move like c6 and
then white tuna yeah
queen h5 i think is playable but there's
a stronger execution when h5 could run
into king d aids so yeah yeah bishop
they got seven is more forcing as a
beautiful combination given that the
queens and a line on the v rank FG six
there's 96 now he didn't walk into this
exact position because he realized that
after a bishop to get seven something is
up and he saw the tactic with queen h5
coming so he played king d8 here but
then white is is having a nice advantage
and guy played forget if I played Knight
e4 Knight c3 if I move the knight back
and that black is uh is not happy to
have the King in the center for a long
time so it's a useful drop to know is
white and if you're playing black in a
position like this you should notify 906
and that's the one thing like about
being perhaps a more like professional
tournament player is you have to be
aware of the potential gambit lines and
just kind of know what to do against
these or have something in your back
pocket because you don't want to be in a
situation over the board where you're
completely like shell-shocked and then
have to start coming up with stuff while
your time is ticking so especially with
openings it's good to be as prepared as
you can beforehand I want to go back and
show just one more variation which maybe
isn't as beautiful as this rook take a
four line but it still still has some
nice venom to it and it's essentially
what to do after a Bishop to g4 in this
position white can play f3 the main move
is Bishop to f5 now if I'm not mistaken
there is actually a game playing at US
Championships in this position within
the last like two or three years it
wasn't the past u.s. championship it was
a game between Fabiano and the Cobian do
you know maybe you saw this game I think
Fabiano we can find this game real quick
I think he played
Knight c3 database might be broken but
maybe I can search yeah he played Knight
c3 and then he it led to a somewhat
complex position but I think he was in
control most of the game I was doing
some brief research and I was finding
that g4 I think is is even more venomous
than Knight c3 not holding back and just
going straight away for the attack on
the bishop and the idea is that after a
bishop g6 and Bishop d6 is a move we
want to provoke then white plays Knight
c3 now in the Cobian game Fabiana played
just to demonstrate Fabiano played
Knight c3 first and after 97 g4 Cobian
played Knight b6 which is a nice
in-between move the difference between
these lines is that after g4 Bishop g6
Knight c3 there's no like immediate
in-between move for black and Knight bt7
is actually a blunder here because it
allows a very strong response from white
f4 and this is ok this is somewhat of
computer preparation but computer will
give like plus 0.8 for whites because
the threat of f5 is so strong whites
also up a pawn here - and I think a move
like Knight b6 is just simply met with
Bishop b3 and black has no time to take
on d5 because that 5 is happening and a
pawn can be reinforced also at Queen f3
yeah
yeah so h6 I assume maybe start with f5
force Bishop h7 them take Queen f3 and
it's just complete domination for whites
so so yeah this g4 move is tricky
because black can't really get away with
playing that be d7 immediately so I had
some preparation here c6 white can still
play f4 and black can't immediately take
on d5 with upon because there's Bishop
to b5 check and a5 is coming in whites
winning apiece so this f4 idea like you
might have to like if you're studying
this is why than you want to use this in
your repertoire you might have to review
this several times so it sticks but if
you remember it can be very powerful
Blackwell is best off trying b5 Bishop
b3 b4 and then white can play f5 and
from what I found this is one of the
best lines from both sides where white
is coming out in a very nice situation
and the computer recommends something
funny here not to take the bishop right
away but just to take the pawn on c6 if
black takes we just leave the bishop
trapped on g6 and white can just keep
improving Queen f3 rook c8 92 and then
eventually okay whenever black plays h6
right maybe even a six and we can take
the bishop and white just has such a
good position from here and this is more
high-level stuff where like if you're if
you're a 1200 player you probably don't
want to memorize all of this but like at
a professional level level if I if I'm
playing a high level tournament and I
know my opponent goes into this line
with Knight f6 I will be preparing these
lines the night before the game if I
have time to prepare and at the high
levels you're usually able to at least
predict what your opponent might play
because most players will have games and
like
database to to search from and kind of
filter through what openings might be
expected so any questions so far about
anything we have some time left we have
one new person emerging okay so I have a
few other things to show and these are
all kind of like tidbits of preparation
so maybe I can just go through some some
quick ones let's go back to an e4 e5
opening have you heard of the Belgrade
gambit okay so the Belgrade that's
another one of these openings is common
among high level players but it's a
great an effective opening especially
for in terms of like surprise value at
lower levels and I've recently started
playing it online and I've had some nice
success with it and it starts from the
four nights where if light wants to play
the Belgrade he can play D for four
nights scotch but then instead of taking
on d4 white complained Knight d5 and
this is the start of the Belgrade and
just to show like one line how dangerous
this could be a fact goes wrong I'll
just show a part of a game that I played
the other day or my opponent took on d5
played 97 I took on d4 already like much
better for white just great Center like
one back white didn't even gown it upon
material is equal when my opponent
played c6 which is terrible move in this
position and then like to move at d6
attacking the knight and whenever or
wherever the knight moves as there's
Queeny for Czech and black has to block
with something on e7 and white just wins
apiece I can actually go ahead and show
the whole game because it was three more
moves after my opponent went back to you
seven with the night I didn't take it
immediately so when there's a pin to
piece you don't always have to you like
take it like this there's not always a
rush
I played Bishop c4 did you see this game
I put this on my YouTube channel and
then in this position my opponent played
like one of the worst possible moves a
five is pretty bad he played that move
which is essentially leading to force
mates what he should have done is play
and move like Queen a5 just give his
King some breathing room but he played
b6 preventing himself from playing Queen
a5 then after Knight g5 is just forced
meets because there's no way to defend
f7 so just a funny game goes to show
that okay with the Belgrade it's
possible to win quite quickly but
switching sites let's say you're playing
black and you take on d4 and they play
Knight d5 this is not a position where
you want to like start thinking this is
a position that you probably want to
have studied before that at least have
some some game plan what to do now out
of curiosity before I show you guys like
the best approach let me get some first
impressions like what would you guys
play in this position you take the
Knights would you take the pawn and do
something else yeah
Bishop c5 playable any other suggestions
okay let me show the the best
continuation for black the best move
here
is very unusual it violates a couple
opening principles but it's incredibly
strong move the more you look at it you
said and I take you for
and i takee for probably Queenie - and
that could be risky I actually don't
know that like the main lines but I know
and I take you for it's not the main
moon night before is actually the
strongest move you move away from the
center you move the same piece twice but
if this is a counter-attack you're just
attacking the knight on d5 and it this
leads to tactics because in many cases
the fact that you're attacking c2 is
quite valuable like for example if a
knight take f6 Queen take f6 like can't
win back the pawn if Knight takes e4
black to move just Queen take d4 and
then there's this fork and black is
winning even more material so White's
actually in pretty good shape here to
our sorry blacks in pretty good shape to
hold on to the extra plug there's
another line where if and I take d4 then
then this is very playable because of
neither d5 is attacks and if an I take
before you're happy to take coming with
in with a check so this is just kind of
a simple thing like if you know night
before you can probably figure things
out from there of course if might be for
bishop or Knight before they take before
then simply Bishop take before and
Bishop d2 Queen e7 I mean black is up a
pawn in doing very well so
let's move on to one more one more
opening kind of like that it's just one
of these lines you should kind of have
in your back pocket so Vienna gambit
this is close to the Kings gambit might
be some cases where there's some
transpositions it starts with Knight c3
the Vienna opening and then f4 now the
you said Kasparov played this ah so not
not recently because as far as couldn't
play this in Fischer random but so last
year okay yeah I think Nakamura also
played this in the US Championship
against honest Shaq I forget what
happened exactly in that game anyway if
you're playing black here the
recommended move is to play d5 you don't
accept the gambit but you challenge the
center right away especially because
white has moved at pawn you want to
maybe open the center and weaken White's
position white will usually capture on
e5 no you don't want activation and then
you can capture an e4 and the line I
want to show the line I want to show
here is what happens after white plays
Queen a3 it's not the most popular move
most popular is Knight f3 and leads to
balance play for for both sides but
Queen f3 is a bit more bit trickier to
deal with because there's an immediate
attack against tonight and it's not
entirely clear how box should respond
because it seems like if you take on c3
that's only helping white strength in
the center and also you're trading off
you're only developed piece so black to
move in this position what are some
other options what to play just to play
that out like Queen h4 g3 Queen g4 and I
take d5
freak on
a five is actually very playable this is
one of the best moves which looks weird
to move your f pong with your King in
the center but if pawn take f6 and I
take it's actually a reasonable position
for black and you'll Castle very early
and you'll have ideas at Bishop g4 and
you'll get some nice setup there's a
different move that I think is even
stronger queenie 795
ooh that's hanging and Queenie seven
might be possible
it could it could lead to trades though
like if not taking for Queen take e5 it
might be possible I'm going to show you
just the recommendation though it's to
play somewhat of a counter attacking
move knight c6 this is a move that you
like if you haven't seen this before it
it's easy to overlook because the focus
is on e4 but you're going for for
counter claim there's actually a really
nice idea here that if might take you
for you don't take back immediately but
you play Knight d4 you said 94 oh you
said Knight d4 Knight d4 is even
stronger because you attack the Queen
and your knight will very soon be
defended by your own queen if we imagine
there's a few traps that like can fall
into like if white plays Queen d3 trying
to defend everything and then ends up
taking on e4 there's Bishop f5 like
blacks piece was just coming to life so
quickly there's another trap let's say
Queen c3 it's Queen c3 let's say you
take
and now let's say d3 okay you saw this
coming but black to move in this
position and win-win material yeah
bishop before so it's quite easy for a
white to just completely fall apart with
this knife very actively placed in the
center and of course after after Queen
take before there's this fork on c2 so
this is just another tidbit of
preparation things could branch out and
I I do have some some other lines that
like we could investigate like Bishop b5
would be the main line here and this is
where I would recommend taking on c3 and
then actually going for a queen trade
I'll just show like what I would prepare
if I if I thought I might go into this
in the tournament Queen h4 trade Queens
allowing white to double these Queen
side pawns but then black gets the
bishop and the bishop can develop nicely
to c5 if white plays d4 we're happy to
trade Bishop a 6 and if d4 again we can
play Bishop to e7 and usually when I'm
preparing an opening at some point I'll
stop the preparation and just have a
position where I kind of know the longer
term plans and I think this is a another
difference between maybe lower level
players and and higher level players is
when when you end your preparation the
higher level players will kind of have
an idea what to do later and in this
case it's it's useful to know like where
where the pieces should go and what the
ideas are for black so of course here we
want to undermine White's nice looking
center and if the position opens up then
the the two bishops will be a very nice
advantage I will also say this was
supported with some computer preparation
I think the computer says like minus 0.5
so it's actually favors black quite a
bit for it being equal material so that
takes us just about to the end there are
a lot of openings I wanted to show but
didn't get to so we might have to
continue this next week
but for now I think I'm gonna end it
there so thanks for watching
[Music]